that mic is too hot that mic is too hot
that mic is too hot that mic is to her
there you go
welcome to podcast Ville in the
Churchill what's happening now the
Churchill what's happening now is
brought to you by on it go to audit calm
for all your supplements your weights
any but steel batts maces they got
t-shirt they got everything me I
specialize in the supplement part the
acai hemp force the chocolate hem force
protein which they routed by the way I
think they might be back in stock
tomorrow how do I know cuz I put an
order in myself also their their main
brand name alpha brain alpha brain 100%
money-back guarantee we don't even want
the goddamn product back that's how much
believe to have an alpha brain go to
adam.com right now and press enter CH
BAM
and get 10% off your first order also
these days you can practically get
anything on demand it's like a podcaster
Church listen whatever you want when
it's convenient for you so why the hell
are you still going to the post office
and dealing with their limited hours and
standing on line like a Mook the law
when you can get postage on demand with
stamps car right now use my name Joey Jo
ey for this special offer it's a free
week trial it includes postage and a
digital scale go to stamps.com before
you do anything else and click on the
radio microphone on the top of the
homepage and type in Joey again stems
comm top radio microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Joey Stan's calm
you'll never ever ever go to post office
again take that melee and
avoid the July it's the [ __ ] third of
July [ __ ] take the stick out of
your ass it's a beautiful day to be
alive and let's do this [ __ ] thing
all right kick that mule either when we
blow up the street beautifully I'll blow
it up how I'm [ __ ] feeling oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
dolly dolly how long are you here we go
this is good as against people this is
always gonna be it as good as it gets
right here
I'm not another lost angel silly enough
are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh come on
what Wow dude if you're not ready to
jump out your [ __ ] car window you
ain't real right here this is and this
is coming at you like a [ __ ] dick in
the ass you'll even see this song comin
at you
Morrison I [ __ ] just are you [ __ ]
kidding me here we go he just breaks it
down
[Laughter]
oh my god welcome to the church Monday
July 3rd you bad [ __ ] are you
kidding me looks like I gave that song
that's not heard that song biggie
this is 1968 I listened to that song
8,000 times confirm waited at my house
they clear that my mom's aw they played
in my neighborhood and we time a play on
the radio it's like I've heard it for
the first time again that's how good to
me that to me in my world that's one of
the top three songs the lyrics are you
[ __ ] kidding me
are you fine if you say those lyrics to
a woman they just melt what the [ __ ]
does he say I'm not right for land all
right let me see
put it on right from there hold on he
says I'd turn it off he said something
just beautiful
I don't even need to I see your hair is
burning yes hills are filled with fire
if they said I never loved you you know
they are alive are you [ __ ] kidding
yeah are you [ __ ] who writes that
alright was a little a [ __ ] genius
who writes - come on guys yeah non spit
did the piece of freaking brilliant poet
Todd you got [ __ ] poet people think
the CIA kills and that was God God said
you know I need somebody rewrite the bud
this [ __ ] dude is dropping knowledge
this [ __ ] dropping doubt if you
would have been there when I wrote it
nobody would've been walking around
confused my guest tonight is my brother
of god knows how long
Marino I might have a little brother mr.
Lisa act you know I think I think it's
you know what can I just like just start
off by saying that holy [ __ ] this is
church this is church no this really is
church and I'm gonna testify why this is
Church because for the last few years
I've actually been talking about the
spirit of freaking Jim Morrison and
people channel that [ __ ] spirit when
you listen to that that resonates with
you and it touches you in a certain way
that [ __ ] was talking to your
soul
you know but there's people that connect
with that dude and I've been like like
just seriously
the fact that it got tied in to the
beginning of your show that's the church
it's almost like oh it was preordained
that it was gonna happen that was the
miracle the Holy Ghost you know was
Santana and I said ah I just thought of
[ __ ] LA woman I don't know why I just
loved it to me all my life that song I
didn't like listen from the early age I
like the song I didn't like when he
starts with the Mojo rising but as I got
older that's the most brilliant part
that all mr. mojo risin he just goes off
the album is brilliant as I got older I
like the doors more and I started
reading about him yeah my mom loved him
she was Cuban she thought he was [ __ ]
the world's greatest looking man and
Steve McQueen she said they could take
over the world at that [ __ ] laughter I
grew up on this music you know it just
just takes me back to a different
[ __ ] time I was as I was hanging I
want somebody actually that that had a
Jim Morrison tattoo and she ended up
getting [ __ ] up and like later in
retrospect I was like holy [ __ ] like it
was almost like the the spirit of Jim
Morrison was still doing [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] you know and being and being
himself
you know people beatin people being them
you know you and I both music lovers
yeah but I don't know if you were played
an instrument I never I I tried the bass
in high school now I could always play
the drums but once I got to pick
something I always knew because of my
coke habit I would burn the guitar or
the drums
shelf life you know were saying like how
long how long five on the guitar so I
chose not to do that you don't take that
you don't bring your own microphone
thank God because I would have been on
my thousand microphone at this point my
career Wow
but whatever I want inspiration brother
whatever I'm lost with a joke I'm
feeling [ __ ] down I put on music
yeah I go to my [ __ ] office I put the
earphones on and I blast whatever's on
[ __ ] YouTube til I can't animal and
it does something to me you're
absolutely right it does something to me
music has always been a kind of a
motivator I hate working at effects
Walkman cuz there's no music I gotta
work out with the iPod you throw a punch
to the bag the [ __ ] earphone about
[ __ ]
so it's uh and then you look at your
life later on in your life that's when
you really look at music you know I'm
trying to write a book so when I try to
outline a chapter I put the music on and
I was listening to at that time and
within an hour if I keep that pen moving
ideas will come after me [ __ ] I forgot
just from listening to that stupid
[ __ ] out bro I mean anything related
to music I was like I was at the Iron
Maiden concert last night and yeah it's
great to see the band but the magic that
happens right outside even before you
get there
it's an event even before you get there
with like-minded people who are like
they don't they don't want to [ __ ]
hurt anybody they just wanna have a good
[ __ ] time and listen to some loud
[ __ ] music I remember a week ago
uh-huh I enjoyed watching live
commenting it like I'm sick of specials
I'm gonna watch man I'm fine with my dog
what's his name crystal did you watch it
yet I haven't yet been gone - I'm gonna
watch man on fire with crystal Lee and
I'm okay you watch a lot of special you
know you tried to you try to watch
comics and you try to
take the whole ow I can't watch my whole
la I gotta watch 20 minutes and go for a
[ __ ] walk and drink a [ __ ] cold
glass of water or something come back so
well you're your worst critic as well
but the other thing is that I love I
forgot how much I love get now and sit
in the back of a time we've all been
watching four or five comics I really
forgot how much you know I remember in
Houston years ago they would have the
open mic from 7 to 2:00 in the morning
and then we'll go what the [ __ ] and in
the place would be sold out and there
was that people want to see a train
wreck there's people that love open mics
you know people want to go to open money
for different reasons I did an open mic
in Spanish a couple of weeks ago in a
bar in East LA so yeah I mean it's it's
in Spanish not 100% Spanish yeah I see
that they do at The Comedy Store yeah in
a couple places yeah Hispanic stand up
making a comeback is it or is it
groaning I'm sorry not okay I don't
think that it's ever you know what
that's funny that you that you ask that
Spanish comedy has is just about has hit
its evolution right now like there's so
much like political instability to say
the least that a lot of these guys
aren't doing the two drunk guys walk
into the bar jokes anymore because
that's what it used to be it used to be
a lot of you know elementary dick jokes
and [ __ ] really like jokey jokes and
a sports story yeah this drunk guy
showed up and blah blah blah blah blah
and it was funny and it worked but that
was the formula and in the last I want
to say maybe 10 years or less the
monologue has come on the scene and
there's these dudes that are like
they're killing it they're saying a lot
of [ __ ] just talking in Spanish dope
spanish 100% Spanish that's crazy
we have watched the Cuban guy I grew up
on the Mexican dude do you know
I thinking about doing it now like I
would go on stage and give it a try just
because it's Who I am
you wouldn't [ __ ] kill it not really
you would that really dudes listen
listen listen listen listen
it's the same I would have to play a
character no no no no no yes I know if I
went up there the only way for me to
make this funny drop trust me Tony a
Cuban i but it'd have to be like one of
the dudes I would have to go up to him
on and be [ __ ] filthy
I gotta member walking while I was tight
with Felicia they love it they love it
he'll try it with Felicia
they love filth and I would walk into a
house every Tuesday in to do a podcast
and every week I would say well if at
that time one is our house cleaner uh
and once it's the kids and takes the
kids to school and I would walk in being
raised how I was and I would go what
Leah wanted did Spanish is she shall we
all say oh well [ __ ] she'd say that's
about five or six weeks since I walked
in one day let me take a chance you know
what I'm gonna go in the kitchen is she
like that and I had like a sunset uh-huh
so she bought right into it I walked up
to it I know you want to reconcile that
means I'm tired and she goes bucket and
I know because I just came back from
Vegas and it was hot and I couldn't
sleep just the air conditioner in the
room then I going on top of that when
you're in Vegas they blow oxygen in the
room and she goes really hard since it's
a shame and I go to anything the only
good part was the pool but the weirdest
thing happened at the pool and she goes
what happened and I go I'm in the water
and there's a gay guy walking past
there's a gay guy in the water and the
gay guy walking says to him oi come on
come on WA and the gay guy goes Depp
inga and the other was one of my teen oh
they're cool right
she looked at me for like a second
that's like a really dirty joke like
how's the water the water is like a [ __ ]
wallet cuz it doesn't translate in
English but I'll tell you what I'll tell
you that these dials Josie died they
love it you don't have been asked
yeah I can hit it with that material I'm
not ready to do material I'm ready to do
one of the characters that will hang in
my mother's bar with that style of Cuban
it's a style of Cuban a lot of Cubans
don't think he'll go over in Miami in
Kendall he's in a while when I speak in
Spanish yeah these are why I speak a
wild Cuban darling a wild when people
hear that they look at me what the [ __ ]
is a wild Cuban that like I've heard
Cubans speak I grew up surrounded by
Cubans Cubans taught my mom how to cook
like they legit taught her how to make
sure it's Cubans where is he thought we
were sort of dude we had Cubans to the
right Cubans to the left
Cubans behind us already the other and I
told her what they call [ __ ] in Spanish
that's how Walker uh-huh Popeye Incendia
oh that's you should totally Spanish
dudes just call beg you up and told you
this she was on the phone going oh my
god it's a legit question what do you
call it there's a money we're gonna tell
my mother
gorila morning yeah pile or that means
they had that hairy spider it's Spanish
they have a thousand names vagina
because they're not allowed to talk
about the [ __ ] vagina it wasn't so
they got a target they gotta be
literally that's where that she had to
have come from they had to disguise the
fact that and now all those [ __ ]
names just kind of stuck is like a
[ __ ] legged I don't almost like a
crazy reminder of the of the oppression
it's a Cuban comedian was very popular
what's his name not angel Salazar not
the kid from The Comedy Store a guy that
does just albums in Miami and he [ __ ]
does these out there Miami [ __ ] Lee
huge and he's dirty
okay you know later on once I have to
for me to write Spanish stand-up I have
to sit down for a while and there's no
way really to work at how just at your
spot once a week but now you have to
kind of pop until it comes for you
you're poppin so so you could do
whatever you're doing in English you
wouldn't have to do a whole different
set you
just do the same thing you just
translate it and a lot of it sounds like
it doesn't translate but you'll find a
word that's funny that still gets the
same point across because the
situation's what's funny and then a word
just kind of helps to sell it and you're
a master words man it's funny because
then when I was growing up there was the
dual name Oh Nina
uh-huh we used to go to my mother's bar
that was a street name Oh Nina
more Nina means in that Spanish about
qua religion moneena if I see you on the
street that's a word of affection this
guy was a sweetheart he wore a wig and
he sold coke so he'd hide the coke under
his awakening I can't write this [ __ ]
bubble Nina had a way with words and all
the for Catholic holidays to cuban
catholic holidays
my mother would let morning a story tell
or tell a story if he did a couple bumps
my mom would have to cut him off it was
hysterical morning huh yeah hombre que
ya father yeah I gotta sell drinks no
same but it was weird that did it's
crazy like every time you say that you
say a very non nonchalantly you know
like very matter-of-fact but you know
you're legit talking about being a kid
talking about you know your mother
checking the mother [ __ ] on how on his
coke intake like that's miracle you saw
no but you saw so much so young and you
were prepared for anything that this
[ __ ] threw at you because of that but
at that age I think I knew what cocaine
was mm-hmm
I knew they were all doing it right I
didn't paint I didn't give them
attention I wouldn't give them attention
from time to time from the age of maybe
seven to maybe the time she died I would
open my mouth about it if it was obvious
and there were people that were
Outsiders never if we'd be at the bar
and my mom
was nine o'clock and I was walking into
the bar from karate and there was a
couple of customers at the bar drinking
people playing pool I put my gear down
in the back and go to the back to the
soda if I went to the bar and she had
white out her nose
and those three dudes and that bar was
back I would say something to them and
then my mom would say something to them
and then I would overhear that blame
they will go around him be careful my
mom what we had a young age right my mom
would tell people be careful kid see
[ __ ] you see yeah everybody says listen
I remember the guys that would go they
would leave there would be a group of
guys that would leave the party and
they'd go around the block and then
they'd come back and they'd be laughing
and they smell like [ __ ] weed yeah
you knew what they were doing everybody
knew that they were smoking bud but it's
like they they left and they had to do
it everybody was drinking tequila
drinking alcohol [ __ ] pounding
cigarettes like it was no problem but
the minute a joint came out the need to
go hide it was so like it like what the
[ __ ] it's so weird I was exposed to weed
as a this is nothing don't worry about
the right row yeah like you find unknown
Bad's gonna happen
and for years I didn't language I
smelled him but had a godfather who
baptized me and he was a [ __ ] pothead
why he who I am today
is him he would smoke and giggle by
himself and it Heinz's get red and as a
young kid I would look up with all this
[ __ ] having a good time even
though I was against marijuana like this
times we thought bro this guy was solid
he would take me every that's no falling
funny so from the age of four and a half
so I [ __ ] ate every Saturday picked
me up and take me to a movie uh-huh we
go eat something feels like a guy then
the car you roll a joint he'd say don't
tell your mother about this
he get high and start giggling
then we go to a movie sometimes the
movie will let me go see his men
was sold out like I used to him take me
to [ __ ] man movies and one time with
the selected group The Love Bug those
Herbie right to get shows like that was
it I was the only man named movie there
was here I was I was a six year old with
the mind of a ten year old really
I [ __ ] Volkswagen that flies around
the air when I my sweet on it he's all
this giggling like [ __ ] this is the
funniest thing it's genius a menace
unless marijuana so it was always the
back of my mind didn't smoke it that's
when I was like my mom had the bar one
night I saw it take a sip of wine so I
waited till she went to bed I took the
whole bottle of wine I drank it what she
woke up she couldn't find we should call
the police they found me in a closet
which shittin people or myself as I
drank the bottle wine eyeballs never
really been my thing in him saying so
the drug exposure my home was very and
then it was like Goodfellas my mother's
friends everybody that my mother circled
did it now here was the fucked-up part
part that if that person had kids I
wasn't allowed to discuss the drug use
with those kids because maybe the way
they were being raised they didn't know
what their family that even though I
know so for example if I went to your
house and I was at cocoa I was seven I
would go to your house to play with your
eight-year-old son might be Siegel jr.
right
why Martine would never know that you
were drug barons and you shot people I
knew because you're like my mother's
ball and I read your reputation at me so
I would be go to your house play with
your kids and I wouldn't even mention it
and the parrots will look at the my mom
and go equal never should we go here so
my mom got it for me I couldn't open up
my mouth at all so growing up all those
years I grew up in like a secret I
couldn't let them know more even when I
was like 10 or 11 and cocaine started
scratching and you would hear rumblings
about it maybe 12 yeah from hearing
people at the bar and you know I don't
already know what people were talking
about so when you think there was no
weed in my house and I knew about weed
when I was in [ __ ] like fourth grade
and we're talking this was the seventies
I was totally against weed and they make
the sixth grade I finally cracked I
grade you know a joint between twenty
two people there goes I'm go to blimpy
base and you get thrown out that
giggling and acting like an [ __ ] and
you'll get patted when I can't go home
why not
they know better than oh no we Visine
yet we [ __ ] hate you with cologne you
know it was what it was a once it went
from Binaca and but after like a
[ __ ] it went from being a once
every three month in and once a month
and then all of a sudden [ __ ] Lisa I
had a student a guy I grew up with guy
who never wanted nothing to do with me
after ten he's calling me up because he
wants to score pound the we even saying
like that's how it went you know like
okay so Lee's smoking weed so it's okay
if I smoke I'm saying like in your mind
you know yeah these are they student
Uli's get another [ __ ] I'm definitely
getting [ __ ] are you sure okay yeah
people are it's weird it's people are
afraid of it they're afraid of it
they're afraid of it and it's kind of
like you know and there's a lot of like
stoner jokes that are probably did a lot
of you know the service you know like
just don't know anything bro like I
forget everything man and say just the
the idea that anybody that smokes is
just gonna just be completely clueless
you know it's not that's not that's not
a fact you know I mean it's funny you
don't give a [ __ ] about a lot of [ __ ]
well you have to build to that point
mine I mean I respected it it was uh it
was a social thing for me hmm I mean
Martin you'll need to go see Apocalypse
Now what the [ __ ] you think we're gonna
do right we're gonna split the six back
yeah you know and we're gonna drink
smoke five joints we're a buyer
what about bro we're not even getting
seven joints we'll buy some African we'd
never getting five joints for the ten to
ten bucks we smoke weed
we then it became five our [ __ ]
sidekick you know swimming
you're smoking this joy with me and then
we'd smoke away only we were getting
yeah I let me tell you something it's
tone that aside walk back into high
school and you'll you career from Boston
so in the winter it's cold
yeah when you walk into the heat don't
worry for intense especially that ain't
we go back to the classroom in high
school and that's how it started
I never dreamed I was smoking marijuana
in the daytime I was not raised to smoke
marijuana in the daytime how old were
you the first time you smoked marijuana
in the daytime ballpark sixteen sixteen
but it started like that you know we
would get out at 11:00 lunchtime like
lunchtime we would play hooky yeah and
by the time we got the beer and we got
to the park yeah it was 10:30 you know
that was my life that was my okay that
was my life yeah but then go in high
school it got to the point where you got
stoned before high school
that was like my Judy yeah like towards
the middle of my junior year I was
actually me or you would go to school
for a few classes and then meet I would
meet somebody like a ten
my friend Devo and a couple of us the
school wasn't I
I mean I'm done deciding learn anything
but it was more of a social gathering
from
I learned I learned food because I would
listen but for me it was like I went to
school the day after my mother died
because hey I hate him missing and B it
was when I went to commiserate
it was my social [ __ ] gallery I shed
a lock with a girl if you have friends
you talk to those dirty animals you talk
to your friends who was in homeroom ya
know it was a social gathering you win
and you got all the information it was
gonna happen the next day or for the
weekend or whatever part I mean um the
[ __ ] that we started talking about this
it's crazy I've been out of high school
ten years I think even now still and I'd
be afraid to go to a class stoned that
that blows my mind I didn't do it on the
Reg but I remember in summer school
specifically when you were saying that I
was thinking how I was there and I had
gotten high before class and I went and
it was like this I had to draw a cube
and like rough with her like a four
dimensional right
yeah and dude do you know how freaking
hard it was to do that stoned I was like
I remember the picture and it was like
all distorted and [ __ ] crazy I was
trying to connect lines and [ __ ] I host
own trying to make a [ __ ] cube talk
in the seventh grade we know was in
seventh grade that I was probably like
in about yeah the second time yeah okay
we would go to shop right right behind
the grammar school we won't look like
200 yards
there was an embroidery factory we would
walk behind there and then we smoke pot
and we go inside the shop ran those days
they made sandwiches believed in that
and we get online they did something so
you didn't smoke in the school
no we spoke softer property we went to
shop right bought something to eat
but shoplifting hubba bubba nice the
whole ten thousand five kids with a ten
pack of Hubba Bubba that means you win a
war from one to three there's gonna be
more bubble gum that's and we would go
back to look already gonna wage with
bubble gum destro of that leave we would
be in the front row and we would all be
barley that day then we would get pissed
people love but I've never forget a
[ __ ] janitor came with a [ __ ] seven
like this like this guy's so he's got
his left hand covering the ladder the
blackboard his way his right hand this
he's walking in and I'll never forget
the kid's name
I am Friends of this down his name is
Orlando South say no on the eighth grade
he sat at the back of the class he was
only those dudes I was a little [ __ ]
fifteen we should we talk on Facebook
now and for years I thought about him
because he did a legendary noise my 8th
grade class was so legendary because we
knocked the teacher uh miss Walsh never
came back miss Walsh or started the year
Thomas how she was 64 she hadn't met
every savage she had been there when
there was no electricity when they had
walked with candles and we were not
gonna antagonize the [ __ ] hurt our
reputation that I thought that I gotta
tell you something miss Walsh god rest
her soul no the first time we tormented
her we told metella till we got to her
and she got to us than the other eighth
grade teacher went on sabbatical in
October they were friends for 40 years
and then the other teacher came in Wally
Lindsey he was a Weehawken mayor he came
into teaching my 8th grade and finally
one day he held us and some guys you got
a knocking off with her because she's
gonna having to bring down and quit or
like he just broke it down for us you
can't you can't keep doing this stuff
bro have one o'clock
from one to three that class was live
bubble gum flying so I told the janitor
came in he came in an awesome Lando
picked up Orlando would get ten pieces
of Hubba Bubba and putting this mouth
that one [ __ ] time
take it out moulded into a brick and
whip it at you oh and the teacher came
the principal came in the principal
there was a guy who fixes the [ __ ] out
of it
came in this all these janitors were
[ __ ] up eagle-eye his I wanna use jobs
deserve to be human shields for teachers
that's [ __ ] crazy you had but Benny
was a high school janitor who I teach at
element then when I walked in a single
benek I got some blackberry brandy where
is it and I locked up we'll get it later
and every class and I got out Benny
would be there
where's that like brandy put in eighth
grade yeah we would throw gum at each
other but every afternoon at about three
o'clock we would do something how did
you burn something at two o'clock I
don't know what's in the back let me
explain
it'd be one guy in the third row reading
whatever the chapter was about maybe
that person will be half of the
discussion and all this side none of no
way it would be like every six minutes
for an hour until she
[Laughter]
so when we were gonna go off like
everything all right so Monday Wednesday
and Friday you have like max from one to
two to three you have like social
studies so I say Tuesday Thursday had a
different schedule every day we had a
different set up for her like every day
in the afternoon was a different set of
torture but it that was the main but
then there was a dude that sat next to
me his name was [ __ ]
Michael Lila Greta this guy was an A+
student since kindergarten see move from
Italy his dad was like a scientist his
mother was like a [ __ ] astronomer
this guy's a Talon this guy's English
wasn't very good but he hung with us he
didn't get high he was cool as [ __ ] know
we gave some bubble gum I won't let
people throw bubble gum at him cuz he
was making kind of in there we play
street hockey we used to hit him in the
shins just to hear him go like everybody
else and go ouch ouch so Michael was a
cool dude but this dude was like a
[ __ ] yeah
like he was gonna go to Yale you can
tell and one afternoon he started with
the set so now it was [ __ ] her
Michael alig Rando and doubly especially
out in stereo going off I'll never
forget this day like yes like if I ever
get to do a TV show this same would be
in it like I have ten scenes from that
classroom in my head that I can't lie to
you as a man this times I think about it
and tears come to my eyes from emotion
like at that time Fleetwood Mac rumours
was the big WOW so that was the theme of
that classroom if I ever write that book
well you don't get to that I'm gonna
have to write in chapters with the names
of the songs because that's it was
rumors rumors was everything you heard
no stop thinking about tomorrow don't
stir everything everything was rumors so
it's Michael nominate miss Walsh I'm
over here you see that death weapon yeah
that's miss Walsh that's how close she
was to me I was in the first row Michael
alig red is right here and Dominic's too
from Dominic swear I am only on the
right side of the class Orlando's in the
deep right all of a sudden she's reading
his book I'm gonna forget this bro comes
flying planes are going off in the air
people are making fart noises and then
it was timing and in the middle of all
this you know somebody would do
something else
and Michael Mata Greta would go WOW and
then somebody else would do something
Dominic specially out or go and this
just went on this was like and gum was
hitting the blackboard you know Charlie
gives he's in the back [ __ ] shooting
planes as they went by
Charlie is he was a kid that sat on my
side he was the last guy in the
classroom and whenever a plane went by
he jumped out of his desk and would go
behind the desk and shoot the plane down
this is real dude he's in jail for
murder tonight what just to let you know
we had a crazy grandma school dog I
gotta write this on paper this is
unbelievable but I'll never forget this
certain day Michael alig rode was
hitting it
whole Angeles house Anna was hitting it
Domenic specially out got rest his soul
was it they were all there Hitler wow
wow
and she [ __ ] took a book and just put
it down and she goes if it's not the
fact that you guys inspired her to what
sounds like a [ __ ] glass she had like
a stroke Oh fine like the eight years
before she had a stroke on this summer I
love miss Walsh and she goes if it's not
the heavy breathing it's something else
when in the world is this and my friend
goes meet the noise anyway through
Facebook meet the noise funny like that
peaches [ __ ] of what if you were that
teacher would you not have laughed no at
the line I was the bad a popular pimp on
my face that was the only one in the
basement this school didn't have a gym
till we got to the eighth grade so in
the wintertime you shoveled snow that's
how you got an A or a B or C November
effect January if you were good shovel
and you had to see those [ __ ] stairs
you had to see the stairs at McKinley
sometimes you shoveled child they found
you to pull-ups and [ __ ] like that in
the seventh and eighth grade classrooms
outside that that was a finale and they
would make you run in there like it was
quite we have a gym so these kids were
shoveling snow shoveling snow and I'll
never forget walking out of that man
when they seen Louis out of are being
grabbed by the principal lioka Tony I'll
never forget this problem and we always
yell oh man Louis was in the seventh
grade big kid that he was cute
because of his skin color well they
still hitting people when you're going
to school
listen to any people oh yeah we they
were walking down and I say they called
him the haru's oh okay because he was a
Cuban do it he hung out with this kid
Juan and now Bernal Wally we'll get to
them later this is all in this class
seventh eighth grade I'm coming out of
the bathroom they're about 60 yards from
me they don't see me I see them coming
towards me because the stairs to my
right-hand side they obviously going to
the principal's office so right as I
open the door
nothing who sees messy look mr. Gay Tony
grab Luis on the bar by his room left on
it okay as they'll walk like the cops
would grab me to take upstairs
Luis outlaw went away Leo the Tony
grabbed him over here on the left side
of the collar and [ __ ] Luis islands
of all unleashed the right hand on them
you understand me when I went to grammar
school unleashed a right hand on that
this teaches like stumbled and went out
from under him bro
and he goes now you're really done and
then Luis code to saying again I'll bust
your [ __ ] mouth and mr. gotelli just
ran away and that's the only poor Louie
in the pilot program when they say was
in high school because you're too stupid
he was Cuban but he didn't speak English
so they held you back until you learn
English in those days you know these
people complain about racial [ __ ] Doug
we can nobody complained as long as
we're learning these kids were just you
had to work harder in the summers but
they lose our levar was part of a trio
of the Ali brothers one and
brother Carlos and colleges little
[ __ ] one said Carlos was on board no
Alberto Ali and Juan Alberto Juan was
the mastermind something like that the
other guy just did next one was said see
he was just [ __ ] he was lost Fez
dark his skin was a little darker we
were as young as we used to jump to
dumpster at dura test and take the
lightbulbs out dura test used to be a
big company injury in Union City and
they made you know as well I both have a
6-feet office once they wouldn't make
those but the duds they would put them
in the garbage we would take them out it
at each other in the head with the white
powder would come on that's why happens
was a dead we inhaled that white powder
in the seventies and they lived close to
that their house so for us to play with
them but the strange thing about that
[ __ ] was just out there for you to have
access to and we also had access to the
but not the factory it was in the
dumpster it wasn't just like yeah I Paul
del Sol light bulb was we'd have wars so
those days I would go up legally [ __ ]
you were not hitting me in the head with
a light bulb
he wouldn't cut himself then he would
just get white dust on his head sure
don't and then it was dangerous back
then I would hit me in the back the
[ __ ] glass pipes those glass things
it wouldn't hurt him you'll execute he
would hit me back I wouldn't be mad and
that's what you did with those things
but I don't know how old that was Adam
let's pretend I'm 12 that was Alberto
one I suppose ladies it's well yeah hang
out with Morton Perez whose father at
the time was Batista's driver so when
they came from Cuba they were base the
money hunt the Perez family dad like
people nobody lived there years later I
went to school Martin Perez was not in
school he had been taking another school
his bad parents disappeared they went
into witness protection
that's how how bad it was that a lot of
people knew this guy was Roberti Stern
cube when they started hating them
and they started hey that his son is
sure like this this is at 12 your where
this love my daughter's yeah that's big
[ __ ] to be aware of at 12 you know you
just said that you know 12 most people
play dates do you think that 12 30 40
years ago was different than 12 today
Jesus by I mean I'm scary about I think
is it the same I think 12 year old Joey
could beat up like it most 2500 Joey
could not beat up a soul what we enjoy
was very shy and skin knows yeah of
course I remember 12 year old Martine
but I'll tell you what I was I was like
this I was [ __ ] yeah mm-hmm I know how
to put two together yeah my mother's bar
I knew what a person was like I know the
[ __ ] we stay away from I'm your chef
from my grandma my grandma told my [ __ ]
I knew [ __ ] that you know like I said I
was raised in a certain number but the
question that bothers listos how much I
want my daughter to be raised at 12 do I
want her to be exposed for the same
thing I was exposed to the only person
was not exposed to that stuff is me by
talking to her about it that's
unexplained ther about what type of
people are out there that's absolutely
and hopefully half of it sinks in and
half of it doesn't dude
I'm that's that's exactly what's [ __ ]
like I think like your your daughter's
how old now four she's for my
granddaughter will be four and I can't
sleep November she's gonna be falling
asleep and I know about the future
listen I'm like look we got to stop
telling them this is what I'm talking
about on stage when I do my little
unspoken word with the music instrument
that's what I'm talking about how how do
we keep treating our daughter's
different that then our son's we expose
our son's to a lot of information a lot
of crazy [ __ ] that we want to shelter
our daughters from 100% we're gonna
protect them from it I'm not gonna
protect them from it we're just not
gonna talk about it it's not gonna take
away the fact that that shit's out there
watching you know when your daughter
Norma
time into Sun gangbanged the three
chicks with alpha robots there's things
that your kids need a little and there's
kids that you think need to know maybe
later as a joke at a dinner table and
you're gonna sit daddy did you really do
that honey I was a difference whoa whoa
whoa whoa listen there's a lot of [ __ ] I
want my daughter to understand but as
she gets older and she's prepared to get
that information you know I live in fear
she's gonna live in a YouTube Mara
eventually she's gonna put two and two
together
I really wanna understand the former and
I wanna hide the acting from her until
she really knows what's going on I never
wanted to come home and say well my
friends at school or exorcism I want to
be an actress I'll shoot myself just
tell me you're bringing home a [ __ ]
ices for dinner it's the same damage
you're doing to me but you can just do
so much for your child there's no
perfect parent no absolutely not
if you want to say it's a 50/50 toss-up
listen man I came from my house of love
but it was too much exposure too soon
for the computer
Antonis in the computer the computer
changed the game
no little for the computer oh I thought
you got that come on look I don't
believe I believe that when you kids
seven then you're rolling reefer and
funny a child I'm not being judgmental
just giving you a bump I'm trying to
thought here you're all enjoying the
filling instead of blowing this you
didn't want them when you're seven your
dad is your idol your dad is your hero
your mom is your hero once they put two
and two together like I did this is why
I make these statements because I did
mm-hmm
what's that put two and two together
those kids have I avoided 13 I avoided
for so long
until one day I go wait a second me and
Lee are seen at home watching a stupid
[ __ ] will found movie and all our
other 13 year olds and behind Nikki
suazo has sucking titties and finger and
shakes the smokin reefer
maybe we should smoke pot what do you
think Lee I don't know
Joey can explain your secret tell that
one I found I found about a year ago I
went to my dad's room to get a check for
school and I found a bag of marijuana I
know what you do whenever I touch I
didn't tell my mother
it also leaves my best friend not only
my mother smokes pot I come in there
smelt it one day Joey and you didn't say
nothin to me Lee so guess what both of
our heroes are compromised them now it
leaves us a doubt where before we would
the gun now which I would never Martine
I saw in front of my eyes what was going
on as a child in front of me I had
cocaine had marijuana and alcohol and
something that also existed in front of
me but I never really talked about not
on my mother's angle my mother never did
it but I saw people around as the
heroine so I saw all for those and I
agree that those are dangerous as [ __ ]
but again I I would not put marijuana in
the same category as heroin or and in a
lot of cases author and loud with
Charles [ __ ] know I'm still the
Challenger I don't know I'm not saying
you should sit there and blow smoke my
perspective is you're the child's hero
mmm-hmm how many heroes drink and follow
their kid with no problem I'm gonna tell
you something don't come crying to me
when you kid gets his day you are right
don't come crying to me when your kid
you know saying because they're trying
to have me late that parents listen as a
child if I'm at Martines house
and Lee's there and Gabriel's there and
alpha robos is there and we're all 12
laughing asleep I thought you know what
we're gonna sleep alone because all four
[ __ ] our parents are getting together
to do drugs drink and God knows what
else and party then sadly they come back
home when they take us home and then
kind of hell overall then we get to see
it it kind of bothers us escape do you
really want to do something on Saturday
but they kind of [ __ ] hungover you
know bro that sits with you for a while
I don't want to ever even have a [ __ ]
cocktail my house you understand me
morning also what no no I'm gonna give
it to my daughter has the time come but
again I really believe that if you see
your hero I'm doing it so more than
likely you're gonna [ __ ] do it
okay that's your [ __ ] hero that's
your first hero everybody sitting at
this [ __ ] table our first hero was
either our mother or a [ __ ] father
okay and some of us could handle the
drug use and some of us can handle their
shortcomings but some of us good Anatomy
and I said yeah I didn't mind that my
mom smoked my mom my mind that my mom
drink and my mom thank God I didn't take
that [ __ ] from her yeah thank God she
was was [ __ ] idiot someone's drinking
9:00 in the morning a mannequin with
tomato juice in it you know when was one
of those people because my mom owns the
bar my mom knew one thing if you're an
owner or you behind that bar for you to
sell drinks you got a drink right for me
to effectively sell drinks
I gotta go that door for door with Lee
Lee wants to come down and drink dog
Lee's not having a good day let him just
[ __ ] [ __ ] friends from the movie
dealer but guess what if Lee's got a
pocket full of money Uncle Joe a drink
with a moral fall in the morning and you
gotta have a cut-off blouse that at
least shows cleavage that's how you get
people [ __ ] drinking you understand
me
and that's how you'd fill up that dead
drop and if your stupid boyfriend since
at the end of the table and sits there
all night
you're not gonna have any [ __ ]
customers because the customers are the
[ __ ] drinks and the tits that's what
attracts those [ __ ] drinks to sit
there like hums off
can they my mom had the system he would
have bartenders no husband's no
boyfriends allowed on the premises don't
even have them come pick you up we'll
pay for your cab we don't want nobody to
know you have a boyfriend you always
been single take that wedding band off
take that ugly picture you [ __ ] kid
off your [ __ ] neck you don't say my
mom knew how to sell alcohol that was
her job to sell alcohol my mom do if you
got four people one time and and the
services of performance that's right you
can already see the bartenders do their
thing they entertain you now there's no
performance I tell you a thousand times
twenty years ago to fly in this country
I gotta tell you something with the most
confidence attitude I've ever [ __ ]
told you Lisa yo you're Jewish little
mind is gonna freak out I'm right if I
tell you this 50 years ago 20 years ago
if you got on a plane and you were
handsome you would dress well and you
drank and you know how to mingle you had
a 60% chance to pick up a projector on
the plane
what people just walking around walking
around walking around people would buy
you drinks
put you guys drinking pick up you three
cocktails over there next e no excuse me
for a second
can we move our seats over here these
four friends of ours you just met him at
the airport
you just met him online you just met him
at the at the bar they told you they
were going to [ __ ] New York - and
next you know that's three people six
people together buying drinks and
drinking next you know another guy comes
over you guys know anything about LA
yeah man I used to live there
where's the Sunset Strip oh [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] party Jesus I got this coke in
my pocket let's go to the bathroom do a
couple blasts that's what flowing was
why would a mile-high club thing began
it's how you how many [ __ ] first class
and all these levels were completely
different a little before I started
bringing the coke traveling coast to
coast plane for all double-deckers guys
were there less see first class was
upstairs there was less sleep even coach
you didn't say like an animal tyfa coach
was smoking cigarettes so the people
wrestling in the back they all knew this
average hey let me get a cigarette
all right were you from I'm from
Connecticut on from [ __ ] base your
old [ __ ] let's have a whiskey that's
what I brought what time I was on a
plane and I was headed I was moving to
Colorado Springs in my mind it was over
I'm moving to Colorado Springs and I got
in there [ __ ] PJ
people's Express was a bottom line for
people who party and did blow people's
Express was probably but I'd love to do
a documentary on people's Express and
see who really owned it it had to be
cocaine people because their first
flights were a [ __ ] they only went from
New York to England New York to LA and
New York to Miami but the secret about
Miami was they flew that way five times
a day no reservations they left at 4:00
you had to be at the airport at 2:00
what time frame was us whatever in years
yeah
83 to about 89 Wow I think I sank them
in when 86 because you could pay on the
plane are you with me yeah see we're
gonna get in line like so I they flew
out of Newark so you went to Newark
um I got online and sometimes you were
lucky sometimes I go [ __ ] take me
back I'll come back tomorrow I'll come
and yell yeah I won't you been online
for a day [ __ ] it because it was cheap
it was $99 $69 from [ __ ] Newark to
Los Angeles oh but it was $3 for a can
of Silva $5 for a veggie tray one $3 for
a pillow
$2.00 for a blanket you know they didn't
charge for luggage but they did
something else that [ __ ] that's so
[ __ ] crazy so what you did was you
ran up a tab on the plane and 40 minutes
before you land the woman would come to
you with the old credit card things not
even the computer you give him whatever
Wow finish your ID that's the last thing
they want it was ID that's the last
thing they wanted was I
they would know you were fake till you
landed with 20 miles on the other
direction that's when they were running
though this guy's afraid this credit
card stole I will [ __ ] them we were
[ __ ] them up but he was the beauty
that's not even the beauty here's the
beauty with how to justify the statement
I made the [ __ ] you know Marty to
justify that statement I make the mud
team they haven't tell you why it's made
this statement because right about the
time
Miami Vice came out just throw them
peoples Express history of people's
Express people's Express got very poppy
an 83
because in 1983 they left North New
Jersey on the hour every hour guess to
where Miami here's the beauty of it from
8:00 in the morning to midnight
it was $69 and from midnight to 8:00 in
the morning it was like $29 Wow
so that meant me you and Lee could be
and a [ __ ] ball would people's
Express was launched April of 98 right
April of 81 when I tell you I was
killing them there you go look at that
man 1993 people's expressed began
flights non-stop Newark to London brand
bah-bah-bah Jackson go Cleveland the
mouth those aren't the ones I was
killing them on
yeah then they died they [ __ ] one of
the one did they go under six I think
86 meeting yeah that's when I said this
I seized 87 yeah well what the [ __ ] do
you think you're dealing with oh my god
I used to kill these [ __ ] up to
85 I'm not gonna lie to you you're how
much older are you than I then I kill
him in 85 I was 22 years old okay and I
was living in North Bergen from from
February of 83 to January 5 I lived in
North Bergen and since I was Cuban eight
and I knew people in Miami that had
relatives down there I became Johnny I'm
the spot for a lot of people I would
never come back with their money I was I
was 17 and all this [ __ ] was going off
this [ __ ] was LAN fire so now you and I
can be snorting coke right like I would
bump into you at eight o'clock on a
Friday night after Miami Vice right
don't even worry about that
I would hook up with you on Friday about
10:30 at the Miami Vice we go have a few
drinks we pick up a package at the bar
and also we get to chitchat one thing
leads to another Ewing you know what I
got this [ __ ] Cuban girl bein in
Miami I really like to go see her and
you get a package of Miami more Kane
[ __ ] yeah brothers a deal well slow it
down they gave me an ounce of $55 at 25
cents or what the [ __ ] are we doing here
we were just get in the car and drive to
Newark Airport no luggage that's a type
of savage I was there no luggage we'll
worry about luggage when we get there we
get the people's Express wait half hour
bull if you didn't get on this way you
got a nice
didn't matter because we havin a boy was
smart and Coco attaboy dog we're having
a good time no matter what you get to
that ball all those people at that bar
we're also snoring coughing they were
also waiting on Miami to do the same
[ __ ] we were doing morning it was
surreal never thought I see a cop back
there people going to the bathroom it
was like everybody on that plane was
coked up and I mean [ __ ] was blowing up
back and so I head out of Miami they
were one an hour too but out of Miami
there were Bulldogs and those days that
bye-bye 83 in Miami by 84 you couldn't
fly out of Miami away they had him
locked down they would pull you over for
no reason I think I don't cook one time
in Miami
I jumped 20 ounces on that and then went
back like an hour away then took it out
of the [ __ ] garbage but she hit the
fan in Miami didn't it wasn't like [ __ ]
getting blown up and explosions here and
there and people getting blasted I don't
remember at that time everybody was
trying to become a millionaire everybody
knew that an ounce of cocaine in New
York was 18,000 $1,800 but if you flew
down to Miami you get that same cocaine
three dollars there's not a [ __ ]
human being that's not bad and guess
what 60% of those people got robbed at
gunpoint Wow 20% of those people got
sold [ __ ] how are you getting it back up
to New York though just fly with it go
right but you gotta figure out a meal
you got to get a mule those days you
gotta pull the guy on the train with a
guy behind number
oh you know and that was I think I pay
$1,000 to hide being a buddy figured out
how to go on a play with four ounces I
could take you know because in those
days I was getting him in a [ __ ]
jewelry box thanks oh the guy with a
prepackaged with your jewelry box put
him in my luggage and hide him really
good that she gets Gary I like traveling
with the coke on me so I could watch
that [ __ ] [ __ ] it was like
you're responsible for that thing you
got to travel with I don't know how many
[ __ ] times I travel would blow on me
and on the plane I couldn't resist him
dog I'd starts north of that plane and
then I'd land that I'd be [ __ ]
hammered by those days like I'm telling
you guys 60% of that plane was drunk I
can imagine this being an episode on
blocked up abroad no seriously like this
is this place basically you know
everybody would want you to feel bad for
these people then get the rest of these
other country I try to be cute
I have zero [ __ ] sympathy for you my
friend
oh yeah that's why you tell people all
the time bro before you go there that
both my fila
balls tell a peeler because your entree
you don't know where you don't you don't
know what they do what you get smacked
in the riskier for could be over there
can be murdered you're not gonna need
tours to North Korea yeah no no no my my
business
listen I don't have a passport but in
reality I maybe don't want wouldn't you
ever think of that
alright baby you gotta behave you gotta
be that I'm in the murari was scared the
[ __ ] out of me said he was going to all
those countries bro I gotta tell you
something for the first two weeks I'm
really worried about cuz I know he's
crazy we'll take his shirt off in some
way and he's a white dude you tell he's
Jewish
I don't know I'm gonna forget a mohawk
or not at the time you know he's in
Cambodia that scares the [ __ ] out of me
that petrifies adieu like me though look
at this [ __ ] white kid that went to
[ __ ] Korea North Korea which it
should have been shot on and his parents
should have bit slapped them I believe
if your kid comes home with some stupid
idea should grab him by the neck and go
listen before you thought about the
report of that that yeah my kid that
just died yeah they just really started
yeah yes it was all on the dot yeah like
they shot him with like [ __ ] benzo
something to keep him alive for 24
[ __ ] hours just to get him here when
he got off the plane you could tell it
was something wrong come up early he was
like over yeah yeah he was [ __ ] up
policy what did he do the pistol with
the poster off a wall he ripped your
ripped off he wanted the poster as a
souvenir
the [ __ ] poster no Cuba I want
everything don't [ __ ] around oh don't
[ __ ] around
why [ __ ] around get in there smoke weed
I mean that [ __ ] I would not do that's
why I can look you in for 10 days cuz
there's no way I'm gonna give up weed
for 10 days
there's no weed over there there's weed
over me everywhere in every fight
especially then are you [ __ ] kidding
me but I mean do they I mean is it like
other laws like super crazy I don't know
I have no [ __ ] idea but I know
there's weed there it's not [ __ ]
sunset herbal sunset they have be strain
like that they grow on the island they
try their best like they do everything
you see they do it cause there's still
reviving 57s off the water yeah well
totally better for you [ __ ]
here to let you know we're still in the
game [ __ ]
22:50 okay I do in such a [ __ ] look
in here mobile I take you for the river
try to give you [ __ ] education just
go backwards after two days there's a
little company you'll be crying like
that [ __ ] it's funny because you and I
were very fortunate in our careers we
had a very good mentor you know having a
good mentor with what you have going on
and you see how other people act at that
level twenty somebody was telling me
today they don't like how the cloudy
stores booked anymore because Mitzi
would book it hold the guys and then a
lot of younger guys and then you know
and then she wanted the younger guys to
learn from the older guys well you're
not gonna really learn from somebody
when you work with them in at the Comedy
Store you'll learn tricks and whatever
those pepper tricks be it really not
gonna learn how to be a comedian you and
I learned from
two great climbers we worked with we
opened up in a mall those years in fact
and as everything moves forward in life
good comics like yourself for myself we
just naturally branch at PNM saying are
you that [ __ ] stoned why you look
like no no I I believe you
uuuuu seriously like you're somebody
that I respect even man on fire aha
please got the Mexican dude with the
glasses in the colonies about the you
know you you know do you work with game
over the last couple years ten years I
worked with Joe for [ __ ] ten years on
the road you know how many weekends here
and there and you learn you learn the
character of a Clement you learn the
evolution of a comic you learn how the
first Cherry's jumping up and down and
everybody's drinking enjoy now it gets a
little combo but it's crazier another
department yeah I'm saying and how tours
changed because there's never really a
tour
it was then was tour yeah I was the
neverending spoiler to the name would
change but it was yeah it was it was
like a like a like a 20 year journey
like I don't mean I'm not quite 20 but I
mean cable features what celebrated a
yeah there's 20 years of his career and
a lot of it was bad
you know I am you know I shoot I was
fortunate enough to see a big portion or
of it you know from a very early phase
you know I mean he he just I mean he
blew up in front of us in front of us
really you know we saw him go to another
level from you know zero to a billion
the Bicycle Club on 3rd on Tuesday
nights $35 and pick it up on Friday
between 4 and 6 that's when I want to go
to the [ __ ] 7:10 between 4:00 and
6:00 on a Friday those [ __ ]
so it was crazy that we got to see the
hotels have they changed yeah how it
went from plane to buses to your own
personal bus to maybe a private jet to
maybe you know from it wasn't Delaware
no more Philadelphia now you're going to
[ __ ] Europe in Germany they went from
Southwest Airlines to to [ __ ] private
jet private jet yeah and and sometimes
not even Southwest Airlines sometimes
driving in a car you know four people
deep if it's to Arizona or [ __ ]
that's right no or to or to you know
Bakersfield San Francisco's always
taking like a plan
yeah we'd certainly 12 which well we we
it wasn't always private playing the
retrospect I look at it yeah it was very
much Kennison ish without even the
seeming collisions you guys were all
good friends nobody was really going off
the deep end with cocaine or you know
shooting heroin hookers or missing radio
bees very professional it was it was it
was magic magic it was a different type
of magic except the scene a few times
and I can feel the love of the room
after the [ __ ] thing Gabriel go eat
and dirty people you know was either
busy eating like a [ __ ] King and
people asked him for pictures I mean
it's a surreal world it really was it
predicted the end to it to be a part of
that world and be and and taste it you
know and at whatever level it is you
know there's people that have come in
and you know done that Gabriel's brought
out on the road for some for certain
gigs like let's see the the magnet to
because people if unless you see it it's
really hard to ignore it you can't
describe it without sounding kind of
like almost like you're boasting or
bragging or something but it's like I've
seen people like look at look at like
I've seen dude I've seen families
that'll say things like you know we just
buried our such-and-such relative who
was a huge fan and we actually had his
picture of you it was like a shrine to
him that they buried this man with you
know and they all like and then they go
to this place to eat out in the middle
of Texas and in San Antonio I think we
were and they run into Gabe right after
like legit they're there for dinner
after they just buried this kid you know
and they see Gabe and and it might have
been it's it was almost like if you know
like if Jesus would have walked in back
in the day by the way these people not
to see how a really good comic acts yeah
a really good comic just the composure
you know I got to learn a lot from Joe
Rogan guys a lot on the road open for
him you know I added some things I would
say this and why are we doing this why
we're leaving at 1:00 and rocking the
whole day let's put this together and
get the [ __ ] out of here early you know
like I would add some stuff and it all
worked and today that's what the system
I used today I used the same [ __ ]
system every week I was never a
Gabriel's guy I really liked traveling
alone
most of the time to be honest with you I
think it's a big responsibility I like
what Gabriel was doing yeah but it was
weird because nobody was looking at it I
saw you guys somewhere I think it wasn't
her vying with Felicia and I go you know
what nobody has mentioned about this
that this has a Kennison vibe to it why
Gabriel would do you know you it would
take you 40 minutes - you've got to see
Gabriel and there was four guys doing
the 10 minutes apiece for them with
different [ __ ] videos it was
interesting you know and then somebody
was talking to me somebody from the
church recently about maybe in Utah
mm-hmm they asked me if I had seen
Gabriel move or they went to see game
you know he had a halftime during a show
yeah I know mission there's another
mission and it was it was [ __ ]
amazing
it was an event it is an event it still
is an event I mean I shouldn't say it
wasn't a minute still isn't it so you
get to learn oh yeah you see it becomes
it becomes you know I mean it when you
went to one of the concerts there was
that it was lose answer it was really a
[ __ ] it wasn't a stand-up shows legit
cause when you go home you scratch your
head you like I got a reevaluate what
the [ __ ] I'm doing because that was
magical and was magic it was bad and I
said those are the words that I've used
to describe it to Gabriel but we we've
seen a lot of math magic a lot of
magical fun but the beauty of it is
proud of it one day you say you know
what I mean one with Gabriel has I mean
what with Joe Rogan has a lot of
responsibility I just wanted to go out
in the world that I've been in this town
long enough
I want a headline I got the chops I've
got the credits and that's what you're
doing right now you're in the process of
you would tell me you're doing like an
unspoken [ __ ] oh it's [ __ ] crazy
right now let me just add to this
because this to me is one of the most if
I got a cop if I got it I take one time
you were on the podcast and I touched on
it but if I have to go through the top
ten nights I've had and my 20 years in
Los Angeles you know when we first get
into comedy we were very fortunate
nobody calls me for those anymore not
that I wanted or because you're busy
you're doing upon trust but there was a
time where you would get your phone
number and every [ __ ] day that
somebody would have a bar and somewhere
yeah we're doing comedy that night and
you would get thirty bucks and a meal
yeah 30 bucks unlike me on a couple of
drink that let me ask you something can
you get me out of there by 9:45 cause I
have yet to Comedy Store by 10:30 tell
me the truth but don't [ __ ] me dawg
is there a Dodger game [ __ ] tell me
the truth saying cuz ahead of those
spots and it was and you went down there
you got to see different comics and I
don't have that my life no more like
that that's gone but there was a time
when Marilyn Marilyn would call me twice
a week man when was the king of the
hustle say whatever you want about
Marilyn god rest her soul she would call
me a Joey my team whatever they will
drive
those are the fun [ __ ] days that
watch the sad there's gonna be
anniversary ten years can I can I tell
you that that I you know you meet a lot
of people you meet a lot of [ __ ]
people and you know out of a lot out of
what a lot of people that I know no one
reaches out as consistently to say hey
how are you
I [ __ ] love you like you know we
don't hang out all the time we don't
have a budget we we see each other rowdy
you know but but I did you check in and
and you actually genuinely you always
have since I met you you've you've never
stopped checking and saying hey I'm just
checking to see how you're doing there's
not too many genuine people you mean you
know and not and but but Marilyn would
do the same thing you just check me this
little family do it and it was it was
all about like it's just part of it you
know I always felt like : [ __ ] you guys
you guys are what a real real mother
yeah but it's funny I go to this [ __ ]
bar I'd met you maybe twice or three
times before this and we're doing the
show I'm a blast I think man was up
before me you're gonna stays and almost
then there's a commotion I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is and I go Bella
what's going on she goes oh my god
Martinez going outside to fight this guy
I go what he's talking about he was just
on stage and he goes he's going outside
because I guess he says some but the
president thing as a soldier hush what
some [ __ ] crazy and they got the bull
of politics then like ten minutes later
it was the next time you were hosting
you wanna update your shirt was talking
a little bit he had a couple smacks in
his mouth and you went back on stage and
did the comedy and now are you were
friends but you bought him the shot
something weird happened Martina it was
it was it was just a [ __ ] like you
just you reason with somebody you know
when you just like tell something like
you know when you get to that point
where you can't just [ __ ] like look
you [ __ ] you know it doesn't get more
basic than this when you take it to that
level with somebody
no but you you were sorry I came back in
like a gentle
on stage and I always know he's just
gonna throw first I always do some
[ __ ] crazy this is right now was no
hammer that was um that was Rick
promises room and I know bro you BA yeah
it was written by Moses room in our
house but how to be time use this
November
Wow so this had to be what 15 years Wow
15 years ago put of that 2002 lock yes
yes that's why I fell in love with you
when you went you threw a couple
pointers and you came back looking like
a gentleman when I left you guys were
having a beer everybody was happy
somebody was missing it to better it all
happened for the namesake a comedy but
now you're out there and I see you
little [ __ ] Facebook videos and your
Mexican restaurant dog and Chicago and I
admire that you know out there you get
the opportunity to do this you know
until fluffy starts his next tool and
whatever it feels great for I'm happy
you're doing this you have a website a
[ __ ]
yeah how's your dates what's that you
know a website when chess or you yeah
yeah I'm actually my dates on Eventbrite
right now Eventbrite yep Martine Moreno
and what's over there and what gigs ooh
yeah ah [ __ ] bro this [ __ ] army right
now yeah this Friday the 7th magic
appleís is a freaking theater and Santa
Monica dog right around the corner from
the promenade okay it's uh so it's uh
it's a pretty cool ass theater they do
this they do magic and [ __ ] but [ __ ]
it's uh it's [ __ ] sick bro it's
perfect for what the [ __ ] I'm going to
the store girl
Joey must have been there for almost oh
dude listen let me tell you want to star
do I want another star yeah you know
what
there's no way in [ __ ] like when you
call yourself a savage
there's a lot of people that say [ __ ]
Savage and they just throw that [ __ ] out
there you [ __ ] are savage
really through no [ __ ] that
keep up with me put on the national
anthem it's fun I'm in here trying to
[ __ ] focus like out like a [ __ ]
focus
let's sing you fluff firecrackers no
Julia firecrackers you're not gonna eat
two [ __ ] stars finish this ugly yes
we do isn't little bean you like [ __ ]
gentlemen finish out what's in this bag
no no then do what we'll do I mean no
don't tell me [ __ ] know there's so
hope we gotta tie you up and leave you
in here for three days
how much is this one I would sit enough
for you how can we give you two okay
good thank you you're gonna need a half
of 125 whatever you do I'm not no okay
so wait I'm only so that would only put
me at 3%
yeah so what percent is that okay okay
I'll do one more red star how about that
just listen
what's the difference between a red star
can't just do one more one more ready
yonder one more purple yarn you promise
there's only a couple listen this this
fall it's two to be fair look at this
we're done for the week
no or not about what I love you reason
why these are 125 this is for a
different mission we use it you know we
can't we have the 20 to 125 just to get
the party stuff did you guys are like
Rick and Morty problem we got it we've
got two little stars here they started
with like 20 friends and they all got
picked you're gonna walk by these little
[ __ ] look how they look lady they're
crying please please you gotta eat two
of them those two came together you know
how we do it it know what's two before
and 22:50 is what I wanted 2650 news
that's crazy would you do what would you
do 2450 I want to watch you toxic I
don't trust you Wow
let's go what's the problem here
listen this latter there you go there
you go oh [ __ ] it's time [ __ ]
it's over it's over we eat that last
[ __ ] star like this like a soldier
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
do you understand that my 125 is just
kicking in hard as [ __ ] that [ __ ] came
in like a swamp like a [ __ ] wave let
me face from that 200 it from the bottom
of the bag it filled take that off
that's not the one look there's no way I
could keep up with you [ __ ] there's
no way I said even dream on if I don't
want anybody ever come on this show
uh-huh
and think for one second yeah but they
have to keep up okay we just waited to
come on the show good have a good time
yes don't denials I'll get some water
that's a no bond to the to a man about
music and how long have you been an Iron
Maiden fan for oh my god bro since I was
in freakin high school and I add let me
tell you came up with 666 the power of
the Beast
oh I was already in you already an old
one before that
run to the hills [ __ ] first bullets
decks around was with them was run to
the hills right the video with the
Indians is [ __ ] that's when they played
with Saxon at the park in Long Beach
arena whence apparently is that one I
sure was cuz if that's when I was and
that's its guy no no no no yeah but yeah
that I don't know when Paul Di'Anno left
arm made yeah did he be boarded
Dickinson take it away from him I don't
know Papa I think what the like that
time there was a different time yeah at
that time we had cream magazine
yeah and something else I saw your
circus magazine sir that was just [ __ ]
badass so hit Parader
well I was part of the church family
yeah founded at a [ __ ] that's what we
had yeah say you have the Internet yeah
you go and read it and find like a
chatroom and some you'll tell you what
really happened
what I heard I work at the Music Store
and when he comes into my guitars and he
left the band he started a new [ __ ]
band now you know you got all this
handful available to you well that was a
kid I had no info but something leave
and somebody's a band why would a [ __ ]
knows who the [ __ ] wanted interview
blacks a do you think Barbara Walters
wanted to have Black Sabbath AHA did
like I got five I got introduced I got
introduced to metal and early in the
early 80s and in high school and you
know before that all I knew was like top
40 and my mom's [ __ ] Spanish music so
metal was like a [ __ ] like a culture
so it like I started getting it in small
dosages and before I knew it I was just
like [ __ ] I look this is the [ __ ] that
I like I enjoyed this little bit but you
don't make your full [ __ ] metal but
there's a lot of Mexican metal go oh my
god a lot of Mexican metal get [ __ ]
into it ticket miss Church they're ready
to [ __ ] go yeah they love that and
they don't care as long as it's a band
that they remember that reminds them of
the time when everything was [ __ ] just
like you know what yeah this was cool
that I want more of this how many people
liked the show
oh they had have been close to 30,000
how much was the ticket [ __ ] I think
like [ __ ] I have no idea to be honest
I was invited a friend of mine hit me up
freaking uh Richard hey his brother he's
the dude I get furniture from this guy
hit it hooks me up with [ __ ]
furniture this [ __ ] oh he doesn't
hook me up with furniture we're like
when I want [ __ ] late
he made me an orange [ __ ] couch bro a
giant orange couch like the vibe you
have in here I [ __ ] love it this is
like semi what my home looks like this
is awesome like I I like this vibe I
like the feeling of this it's like
orange couches I love them what kind of
material it's [ __ ] like it just like
a regular couch like a like a big old
big old futon with not full-time like a
like a big old couch like a sectional
with [ __ ] the Ottomans in [ __ ] okay
but that's like all a giant big orange
one and that's what I want too we don't
feel good that couch is nice
yeah please the only one that possibly
possibly kind of farther on it but
besides that nobody that definitely
farted on that card is a virgin oh great
well thank you that's so that's so
that's a very that's very generous okay
appreciate this would be a nice spot if
you were a single dine you can flip it
and keep your [ __ ] low yeah and I bring
know what this is a nice young I don't
know being a kid thinking I can't wait
to be older yeah I'm gonna get like a
shitty apartment where like Charles
Bronson Bush not even death wish there
was a movie air war and death wish he
had an apartment and that's where you
store those guns and his suits and [ __ ]
they would kill people and I always
wanted that same little apartment that
might I can't wait to live like Charles
Bronson I think about that [ __ ] now
dying alone [ __ ] you
nobody wants to die alone you gotta get
a girlfriend jack oh yeah [ __ ] that died
alone was [ __ ] that was great the
seventies work vocal Joey don't more
yeah no you uh said you're a family man
I believe we were a family man Joey we
went to San Francisco for a few days to
hook up with her Godfather and I got
father's daughter they love each other I
mean they didn't know each other like
two years this mercy was a baby mercy
closer a big sister who she calls her
little sister in California you know
don't you think I wanted to [ __ ] go
to San Francisco
finish me the wolf every time I think
about Fisherman's Wharf Japanese
Fisherman's Wharf
if you went to any of those doors on
Fisherman's Wharf when this boat when
they're [ __ ] flabbergasted then I got
a really ask you Friday
and if you use your credit card there's
some the 50 bucks and then everybody
gonna ask you for ID doesn't even gonna
call don't even ever run it they gonna
put it that machining or Cheech
so I would haul tomato that was that
thing those they asked all day a name so
let's pretend you came to me out of this
listen listen come here for a second
there's a lady over there this is how
was this is not water there's a lady
over there still taking your college I
thought you would have you got a color
another 30% okay
and you go and get ten [ __ ] limps she
wouldn't give a [ __ ] but then you had a
so you don't saying like yeah whatever
you clicked in those daddy's gonna be
able to sell looking like this poor
bastard
did you eat another spot no I hate that
one button my water got knocked out so
those were my two spots yes it was high
volume if they were asked for your idea
what you just say answer dinosaur my
rental car Jesus Christ
hold on let me see if I can see one away
let me get that back kale I wouldn't go
in there dressed like job bomb I would
go and then dressed like Don Johnson in
that thing has to have a white shirt I
would have a gold chain my hair would be
told I would have a jacket I have shoes
and a pair of pants and sometimes I have
a briefcase that's how deep my Jimi went
by those Sundays I just go I don't have
$10,000 in traveler's checks and I gotta
make a living I got ten bucks in my
pocket so I would go into a place by
lady give them 100 and they would give
me a like change back or whatever the
[ __ ] it is I would spend like 60 and
they were having given 250 dollar
traveler's checks and they give me 40
back you know [ __ ] like that you just
maneuvered it like you knew and I forget
all the math in those days how do I get
the most for your money again they'd be
people that come to us and look at show
cash ten of those things but she wants
three of them Father and then could you
return that stuff like her for cash yeah
so you had to have so I don't come to
you like let's say there was somebody
who made pictures and you wanted those
pictures for your bar and there were
five hollers you
I would go then you need a pager salty
for - I don't give a [ __ ] I have no
[ __ ] cost my cost is zero if I go
over here you three of those pictures
will only make later makes these bills
that's a deal to a guy like you there's
never gonna cost you five on you I
should really be talking to you 250 but
I like you [ __ ] just gonna be -
when I get you three of these yeah
probably go to Fisherman's Wharf in
those days than just cash in [ __ ]
credit cards cash and traveler's checks
and now you're walking around it was
crazy because I little were back there
again
oh I left there at 85 the cops are
looking for me and that was the end of
that nothing was ever heard about San
Francisco again I left some jewelry
pawned in a pawn shop and my ex-wife
flew back one day a one day trip from
Denver nobody knew she looked at 6:00 in
the morning she was back like 3:00 in
the afternoon and she wanting out all
her jewelry and [ __ ] out of Port Allen
hock but that was it I never went back
to San Francisco and then like in 2000 I
did cops was robbing and I always do
Thursday night and Friday he did a radio
and I found the cab nice to encounter
the Tenderloin I hadn't been the
Tenderloin dog and [ __ ] just a
council looking for me
I'll have [ __ ] had them drop me off
and I walked around those streets and I
remember seeing a cafe and I went in
there and had breakfast and while I was
eating all the memories of me walking in
those streets I mean wow I was a [ __ ]
kid when I was 21 I thought I was the
king of the world at that time I thought
I had all the answers I was pretty
street smart I will tell you that that
by that time by the time I got to San
Francisco I was [ __ ] tremendous I
know credit cards I know Street I don't
drunk I know everything and I knew
weapons by the time I got the same ones
just know I know a little bit about
weapons so I was I was telling somebody
I was a bodyguard phonebook I wrote for
this dude I hit Robin in San Francisco I
mean you're looking at me right now
the comedian drugged is your buddy of 15
years and I'm telling you that when I
was 21 maybe 22 I was a body girl my
mother always tell me about boy
I will cousin boy I don't get that meant
a lot being a cooler well always say
that's a different customers to [ __ ]
like that a Bouguereau was a do to what
the prison in Cuba that wasn't gay but
he would [ __ ] gay guys and let them suck
his dick he was a dick thought that was
a name for that whoever that bro this
guy was a lot a little drug dealer you
have a wife or the kid will they say we
called him gay he would not give a [ __ ]
out cuz he wasn't gay not by no means he
was macho I was like the most
interesting man in the world and he
would walk into the room with these two
guys that we dressed up as women with
like mustaches like a shadow
he's Jose Emily and a wig and made up in
purses like these guys weren't gendered
they didn't do the operation they still
had Nixon so far they just were women
there were prison hoes they were gay men
that went to Cuban prisons of prisons
here
and they were hot they got them above
you saw them unless you look closely and
sometimes you don't know [ __ ] it they
came out of prison oh and we're like
well so so long sometimes you go to
prison game yeah okay so Joey Diaz finds
out okay
yes cellmate Joey Diaz finds out you're
gay and one night after about a month he
wakes you up in the middle of a knee I
was a Linda McMahon
suck my dick I can't I can't
same things than anything else some way
you gotta work it the same way you lose
it
just a second my dick I spent [ __ ] in
the ass I mean this is crazy that's
crazy it's [ __ ] crazy but it I mean
all of a sudden after three months I go
lean or whatever look like you once told
me you felt like a woman
yes I do
I want you to take those prison pants
and come on hot pants and tighten more
on their ass I want you to get a broad
and fill them up see this again titties
dog oh it's a full blue you have no idea
oh no I these to a full blast Harlan
[ __ ] but he at night he would go home
back to his family but in the daytime
they work this like Bonnie not really
bodyguards but they stood next to him
they pass the drugs along to people if
you hold the money you give them the
money you know big Cuban production ends
in Bingham a gangster production
slinging [ __ ] dirty dollar bags on
the floor sound like they tried to hide
it at all
no no no swinging $30 bags on the
Tenderloin from [ __ ] 11 to 8 o'clock
at night like any other
but no one day I'm friends of this kid
Babu see Hawaii's the hustle with Cuban
kid and one day those dog tomorrow gotta
do something
are you busy
he goes do you have a garlic or yeah
goes can you bodyguard this guy Lamoni
was a piece of cake is three L's and you
stand on the corner and you made sure
nothing to [ __ ] that Mister that's it
he'll pay you three holes at the end of
it I'm a young [ __ ] game dog
so 800 bucks for your life so there's no
life I got a gun I got a gun I got extra
bullets I got a claim you're invincible
and I'm invincible in my mind I'm 22 I
got no family I have no mother my
mother's dead or I give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it I'll be his [ __ ] body God the
first day doing Ana my mother would
always say that word to me to who I roll
up another pass on all these things let
that first day it all comes to me I get
there I introduced myself I see your
thigh retopo like I've seen in the
neighborhood but an hour later [ __ ]
The Supremes come down they're both
Cuban chicks they're guys but they
dressed up as work they come out and
hang out like Farrah Fawcett and the
[ __ ] Charlie's Angels minus one right
like they're really women done like
they're pushing it and guys were walking
by and then look at them and everyone so
long he would go what the [ __ ] are you
looking at - like the women what are you
looking at him for that [ __ ] I met some
guy in town some sad I gave him and the
gay guy would squint oh there was some
guy thoughts when we just Mack yes when
I got it and the gang guy would the next
night he said - that night he goes
listen can you do it again tomorrow
even in Memphis he comes on one extra
help around here we're getting too many
cops I want you to keep your eyes open I
was sure I came back the next day the
next day was completely different same
thing he came out they come out like an
hour later after they made out he sleeps
somewhere else
they hold the coke from upstairs they
probably had another stash apartment at
the time but they all tried a hotel room
and I don't know and they don't look the
corner from the Tenderloin there which
is still there I'm not sure if it's
Doyle it's across from the hospital
there I don't know what's name and I
don't that know Farrell maybe it's
wherever San Francisco Hospital is right
across the street from their caddy
corner there's a hill Ness where he
would get a room there he would have a
room with the two gay guys on the
Tenderloin and probably one of the gay
guys had another apartment so it was two
guys but they live in one and then have
a stash room in one apartment this guy
was bringing the Koken from Miami and
when he would come in everybody would
hop for him and he would swing his
product on the tenderloin there was two
blocks then what he just lung product
some people came for 20s some people
came for 60s some people came for a half
a kilo
mom's right upstairs and they would go
up and get the batch when he wanted
something that was big that he didn't
have close by to him he would hide [ __ ]
in a bumper like he would hide this 50s
and 20s and bumpers of cars so when you
drove up the chick would take our 50 out
of the bumper and throw on the floor and
you give him the money then he [ __ ]
hold onto the money I have to he had a
certain amount the one gay guy with the
weight would run upstairs with the money
and then come back down and that's how
it worked
so the second damn that and some guy
talks that is [ __ ] the one skinny gay
guy with the wake right uh-huh
and the guy really thinks it's a woman
and he's coming on
this guy is talking to the other thing
with the wig and two guys not even about
drugs they just talking about human
stupidity and he looks over II think it
was all a dad doesn't take a going
deeper with that means stop talking
those rotten in other words I'm on the
[ __ ] corner as a look at mmm next
thing you know don't I don't know what
happens he just turns around yes fudge
punching it just punch it and I mean he
had I had like four times she went down
the floor he kicked her in the stomach a
few times that was just life that was
accept accepted in that lifestyle like
he can beat them make him suck his dick
upstairs beat that you know it was such
a thing I him I kind of heard enough but
not really like I'd never even seen
something like that at 20 years old 22
mm-hmm
he would beat her right there on the
street nobody would say Oh Joe on the
street in public on the streets 50
people walking around the Tenderloin he
would smack them would open him I had my
[ __ ] woke up but I was definitely
maybe two or three other days not to be
insensitive but what do you think they
would have said something if it was a
girl or was it that conflict that they
wouldn't say anything anyways like if it
was a natural born girl exactly I don't
think he would hit him well do because
of this situation so so is more like a
gay bash have everything no this is like
a prison thing like a prison thing this
is how their lifestyle is uh-huh in
prison these Cubans [ __ ] laugh I
gotcha gotcha gotcha that's the way it
was back in the old country
yeah more in prison there's no [ __ ]
rules no musician brought here yeah yeah
you [ __ ] yeah prisons are no that was
a shock the first time then the second
time he beat the other will not be
positive she was bleeding he told us go
upstairs and clean up why aren't you
staying a [ __ ] don't [ __ ] have a
[ __ ] look at me
talk to me like that again that battle
aria that means I break your [ __ ]
life in half
she went upstairs came back tip-top
Magoo with makeup on like nothing
happened
Wow coming up the black eye and that's
the [ __ ] lifestyle I take a beating
hey listen there's a website called
Christian domestic discipline you know
what this is not listen this is these
dudes are [ __ ] did I swear to god
these [ __ ] are just applying it
with the Bible they're saying hey you
[ __ ] up I won't beat the [ __ ] out of
you [ __ ] I decide when you [ __ ] up
but it's like an agreement between them
in this freakin like you dude I was
fighting googling spanking freaking like
old-school seventies spanking and [ __ ]
doing kids or adults no no these are
adults but the dudes are like like say
that say you have a wife right right
that if you were under this freaking
like think the Bible says that you're
the man you're in charge or in control
you think oh shoot if she [ __ ] up at
your discretion
you to say hey [ __ ] you [ __ ] up she
goes she prays she reflects and then you
come in and punish her with the spanking
you sure I know there's people that and
there's like testimonies on there from
these people you know what's that this
is a Christian website I don't know who
else is underneath and you know and this
are faking it that you're a Christian to
join them but I'm pretty sure that
they'd be pretty select there's also
[ __ ] Christians that come up with a
snake
what's that they come up with a [ __ ]
snake and the snake blesses you yeah
that's a [ __ ] year snake bites one of
those crazy poisonous things religion is
what you want to [ __ ] believe hold on
that dog let me give some shoutouts see
you got it this is what the [ __ ] you
want to believe if you want to believe
that somebody beating you to death is
what religion is all about me my [ __ ]
yes
listen we thought were you saying genome
the death
Gino Castro Joe Dominguez Isaiah
Saunders Kazmir boomer will you kidding
me or what Mickey Miller Jeep Jim nunya
Donnie
Voltron from a hundred and forty-four
and [ __ ] Lebanon Street sympton
carpenter no suit stupid stupid Compton
one
Elvia and my main man bill Dolan that's
how were [ __ ] doing it
[ __ ] I know we're taking it to
her we always here it's always a
pleasure to see my little brother like I
said I judge people not really in a lot
of crazy things but when you leave the
stage to get into an argument in a
fistfight with somebody and you come
back like that happens I'm in with you
that means you're a real comic and
you're real gentleman there's something
about you I like and I was always
friends with all those guys you know I
love Alfred and a half it was there when
I almost killed a certain individual and
since that day he's become my friend the
tour manager little Ivan I've always
loved him I mean these guys you know you
go back with them for so long and you
watch them grow yeah we watch these
other grow I mean the time you came to
me you said yeah you know we did me and
Gabriel went we watched your movies [ __ ]
but I almost cried that day I got my car
was like Jesus Christ why would somebody
go see a [ __ ] movie I was insane and
the one with a row yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
did anything that you do anything that
you've done we're big fans we don't know
dude like the respect that then as a
matter of fact listen I just had dinner
with Gabriel couple days ago and you
know I he said make sure you told them I
was coming on and to make sure you give
Joey tell until joy said what's up I
always kind of love from telling the
time on Twitter wanna investigate what
the [ __ ] is going on I'm - all right I
got enough on my plate I got
don't worry about your [ __ ] problems
right what's going on with you my little
buddy saya you're a soldier at that you
don't be dog right I don't put your
nowhere where you don't [ __ ] belong
am you've been like whatever Joey for
five years now you gonna be promoted
pretty soon the capo regime yes please
you gotta make no moves you know you're
right there you've been a [ __ ]
soldier you never late you're on time
you know I can't get you to high because
then you come up with stupid ideas but I
gotta love you you got a lot of heart
for every eight ideas it gives me he's
got one that I wanted to academy award
hey you know what too lazy to pursue
that's good man but that's a thinking
guy right there that's that's awesome
well if you all on this little tour man
I'm happy that you doing so so check
this out Joey I did I just did a show uh
it's brand-new I've got a musician's
with me like I'm I'm doing a whole
different [ __ ]
I got a drummer and a guitar player now
we're listening Morris and earlier how
sometimes Morrison is just talking and
there's music that's the kind of [ __ ]
I'm doing right now like I'm you know
because once we took this play play and
I started just meditating and reflecting
and just thinking about so much [ __ ]
that that's important that that I'd
evolved into you know [ __ ] you think
about the man you are today versus the
man you were just ten years ago I mean
that's what that's night and day our
revolutions you know and so when once
you start looking at [ __ ] in in a
[ __ ] way where you know I think I
just got to a point joy where everything
all of a sudden just just like hit a
place where [ __ ] it you know like like I
think it's it's um it's times that like
you just gotta like take the the
blinders off and say [ __ ] it stop
pretending about [ __ ] you know there's
way too much [ __ ] that that that I feel
I've been lied to as a human being you
know and and that it's you know that
there's expectations and what should
happen you know there's there's these
like if you're not married and have care
by a [ __ ] house and get in that you
know you failed as a human you know and
a lot of people's [ __ ] eyes and and
that's [ __ ] there's a lot of people
that find themselves is up in that
position and are like what the [ __ ] I
followed the rules I did everything I
was supposed to [ __ ] do and and if I
am I not happy why do I need [ __ ]
xanax why I need this people aren't
honest about what they want and who they
like or what or what they want or what
they want to do in life I think we've
been brainwashed to follow a formula joy
no no no the problem is Martin how long
does it take to really realize what the
[ __ ] do you want to do as a human bein
oops a lifetime okay it takes it's a
time is just a gift of life yes that
every day you learn something a little
more you get a little more patience yes
and you [ __ ] find a way to deal with
stuff you know when you're 22 somebody
gives you a finger you jump out of a car
you throw a bottle at them when you're
54 you go to Starbucks to get a flat
white you leave any pot cookie and you
[ __ ] go home and mind your business
it's all comes true where's the MS [ __ ]
like this you know it's just you know
identical a lot of conversations about
the tours with people like Joey we feel
you should know no I can't this is what
I could do the third week of me being on
the road I'm gonna be faking the funk
and people that I know your phone's
Anthea I feel comfortable doing the road
two weekends a month that's what I'm
good for anything after that I'm just
gonna be faking the [ __ ]
I wouldn't be thinking about my family
why I did it two weeks a month is fine
for uncle Joey you know you could do it
you could do brother I'd love to be able
to be like Gabriel go out every week I
can't no more I can't do it it's it's
and part of me doesn't want to do it
it's a lot of work it's a grind so a lot
of sacrifice after a certain point it's
the law of diminishing returns which I'm
a very firm believer the law of
diminishing returns always comes back to
collect for everything is you can't eat
22 [ __ ] egg salad sandwiches a week
but you can eat four because of those
four days you're gonna work out do you
in the fifth I mean it's the same thing
for me on the road yeah I'd love to go
on the road Thursday through Saturday
small [ __ ] theatres it's a lot of
Twitter and a lot of Facebook
I'd have to get a publicist that's a ton
of emails you know which I want emails
I don't unless you got a bonafide
[ __ ] job for me which is fast to me
creepy questions on email that's a
relationship goes sour let's see that's
it's beautiful that you know exactly I
don't want but but what's even more
important joy is that you've you're at
an age where you were mature enough to
say that because you know when you're
young and and you know let's face it
when when Gabe blew up he was a 20 year
old kid and anyone [ __ ] full-force
for the last 20 [ __ ] years
so yeah that's uh you're gonna achieve a
huge level of success and and he worked
he worked his ass off for those 20
[ __ ] years I got on stage the first
time June of 1991 until this day mm-hmm
the question that comes to my mind at
least once a week is what made me or not
what made me pick that fate and in the
end I remember I [ __ ] around for two
years and then after three years I said
you know what there's one bet though
this is how I'm gonna do it
I'm go for it and I wonder fruit ice at
Titan Colorado for 18 was it was going
downhill when I said you know what I
gotta go for my dream you know what at
that time I gotta live here
my dream was just to survive just to
survive get over this pain for this
[ __ ] divorce and do jokes on the
stage and so he'll give me 75 hours a
night are you [ __ ] kidding me
and nobody knows nothing I don't have to
pay taxes on this I'm gonna do dick I'm
just going I got myself this little
Nissan [ __ ] this wasn't a Nissan a
Dotson Dotson Martine Moreno
and I fit everything I had that can be
in a car so I was never bored and if
something ever happened that was always
covered from a thing of water to a
blanket to a frisbee to a football to a
basketball there were pillow - an extra
blanket the radiator repair - a spare
tire - a space bear spare tire - an air
pump if something was gonna happen I was
gonna be prepared I put a [ __ ] pipe
across the room so I can use it as a
weapon also us a hanger I hang my
clothes all sorts of cover if I want to
sleep in my car in some hotel wat you
know you're prepared to survive ya know
that's it I got that I called and I had
this weird dream that I wasn't gonna do
movies because of my past and who I was
and because of my character the fund I
would never be too good to do movies
nothing like that dr. Holland I could
possibly do a stand-up la la we thing
you and I was never in my future plans
when I got into comedy not by a long
shot I thought I was gonna be a ham and
Egger through life and I was gonna be a
ham and egg
when he uses that line in Rocky it
chills my soul because that's what I
thought I was as a comedian I had a
[ __ ] I have a lego we know plenty of
have an actress and that's so great
that's a horrible label to get put up
it's a truth that's for sure you were
having anger dog you had a show you
relied on it to show what under you want
to know you never were a lot of fan
bases they were relying on your people
you know just came to you because you
were special it happens it happens this
parade and from that it teaches you how
to do it again most people fail in this
career you know for example I use them
constantly Tom Rhodes and Margaret Cho
and what's-his-name the kid who killed
himself in the hotel room died god bless
his soul Giraud what sir then the
Spanish kid that from New York Oh
[ __ ] Freddie Prinze no no not a
[ __ ] Freddie Prinze drawers are
special oh yes they all had TV shows
that we're all plotted to see if the
comic John would work and when the
numbers went out they pull the [ __ ]
plug time all three of our shows because
they were looking for the next Roxanne
Roseanne they were looking for the next
Tim Allen when the model didn't fit they
pulled the plug that those guys took
that 60 percent of countless will tuck
that tails between their legs move back
home dumb local comedy or done radio
comedy in blah and been terrified and
furious in Hollywood I always give extra
props to [ __ ] Geraldo God rest his
soul
Margaret Cho and Tom Rose I've had Tom
Rhodes on his podcast various times
and the respect I have for him is
because of that because he took a defeat
that between you and I is met Liam Tania
how does the I can handle Wow if I had a
TV show for three years after the first
few you go grows a little bit but it's
not Stern because you just got a second
year that don't mean dick once you get
the third year you start talking [ __ ]
dog
you still looking at houses Wow you
still looking at your wife was she the
Sailor this broke-ass [ __ ] I had two
kids with started to get a new one I'll
keep her around to raise the kids then
I'll get myself a fresh freak fooling
around with a packet or a car nobody
knows nothing you know how do you know
what my point is nice Tom about Tom
roads but about terminal that's not got
nothing yellow till the money that
there's God yeah but um kept doing
comedy Margaret is better than that but
tom is better than ever when I really
thought about queens of comedy six
months I made a promise to myself that I
was gonna see every headliner and
everybody and just dress up and pay for
the ticket not saying it I would always
go in once the show started
by the time the feature act was getting
off and I would sit there and I think I
watched six headliners in the week all
different styles well one of the best
guys I want to know six weeks is Greg
Geraldo I learned a lot
there's a freaking genius was very it
was very great than what so my point is
that all that defeat [ __ ] is what you do
it you know I'm talking the first ten
years I was here Jesus Christ I heard
more nose than [ __ ] anything though I
heard no for everything
little festivals big festivals rolls but
then you just need to learn to deal with
the punches and you play the odds they
can't say no forever can't say no
forever I've been all these auditions
and tell them years ago more but they
would say to me you know what we don't
think he's experienced enough for that
role that's a but you know we go into
these roles they're loud [ __ ]
going I just know you are why don't we
listen Jeff Gallen signed me in the
summer of 98 after I shot the pilot for
CBS when the pilot then get picked up I
was very fortunate Martin Marino this is
one if you were a stand-up and you had
one credit they were looking for a role
in a movie or a TV show you could talk
to casting director in those days and
from looking at his three-minute tape
and reading your headshot and deciding
have that dude wonder anyone I think of
water yes please
I could see Lee's over there Frank yes
what was that dude Jeff gently with that
little resume the pilot the Taco Bell
commercial and bass ketball he got me
out for so many things I wish I have
never recovered those notebooks I
recovered his notebooks from 2000 but
the first year but I went out with Jeff
Gallen
and I got no reason to lie about this an
embarrassed because you guys don't know
what it's like to go to his [ __ ] I felt
in my heart I was a minor league dude at
that time I've been doing comedy seven
years I can have wine in a [ __ ] sea
room but I didn't really have all the
tools to be able I was just up there
telling dirty jokes and shitty [ __ ]
kind of looks giggles and told me I was
funny buddy to have it but I could act
to be a good criminal you got act Queen
Latifah significant act you know and
that first from from 98 that I sign we
get it 1099 a half Martin yeah I got
nothing and he would send me out to read
a four times a week I'm talking about
[ __ ] movies I'm talking about TV
shows roles that you and I would look at
the angle how the [ __ ] did he get me
ever movies with Travolta movies with
the first one were Will Smith in the
[ __ ] guy did the Martian ah man black
but in black the fries still not on all
the way the producers for one of the
roles of men in black
it was only two days I've been in Black
II when I was gonna beat up or King for
hit would slime is some [ __ ] Rhona crash
but if you look at [ __ ] though just
saying man I'm black man in black a
little casted my name is Roma cress I'll
never forget you I listened you know
many times I went to the audition four
[ __ ] times so in those days I was
going to first I would go to auditions
for a year and a half and nothing
happens guys nothing happened the even
said to me Joey what the [ __ ] is going
on and I got a little jump yeah no no
what the [ __ ] is going on and I said
[ __ ] I bombed that the improv behind
Nick DiPaolo and Doug Sandom and I said
you know what I can't have this
m'elmoyle where I do comedy so I signed
myself up for a triple one who was a
roll across the casting for men in black
yeah it says David Rubin and Deborah
Zane no I wasn't rolling crass or either
look at men in black 2 maybe I'm wrong
who the [ __ ] knows I'll never forget
where all the crushes have Sony the back
lap like you gotta go down the front why
were you going to like that like the
back lot to be in the back line of a
[ __ ] you gotta know people and
[ __ ] you've been around for a long
[ __ ] time bro [ __ ] yeah I remember you
gotta go back then they offered you
water
yeah and I rent for men and black either
first one the second one and I'll never
forget that I was like holy [ __ ] this
guy's got me going down
yeah is the second one the second one
roll the grass bro I went out for
everything those day I would go dishes
from the old Jeff the same me he would
go go in there read the [ __ ] roll
luck among their feet and then one day I
started one bastard I booked the show on
NBC 4 episodes recarey
the whole time my [ __ ] hand was
shaking when I booked it but she got mad
at me because I told that they want to
come in and read for this role I should
go to wine I go I'm not this guy she
goes who do you know just read the role
and she goes well canceling your trip to
New York coming back on Monday for
producers and I went back one thing I
got for / so I swear my mother's a great
bro and this is the thing you don't want
to go out or they said to me hit your
mark I don't even know what they were
talking about think I'm saying sir he
and Mark I'm wait what are you saying I
just hit your mark I'm like what are you
talking about like sir step up to that
line like I didn't know anything I
didn't know about action a cut I knew
nothing
the wrenched those people were the
nicest one of those people it was Sidney
Poitier's daughter and somebody else's
kid and they were the nicest people in
the [ __ ] world to me I'll never have
never forget them gold because they
loved what you were doing I didn't even
know what I was doing morally but that's
the thing I didn't know what I was doing
I was [ __ ] my [ __ ] pants I was a
[ __ ] plumber who I was I was a
plumber to the campus they were all
lawyers and one day I go in the bathroom
episode 7 I go in the bathroom and I
find toward your panels of we'd the wall
and I told these law students and they
take this was my big break in acting
this was it me and Jeff Gatlin won a
role at that time I booked American gun
with James Coburn I booked the show with
Arliss
I booked a father he kept saying to me
Joey big mafia things are gonna happen I
want you to take he was very smart
there's no way he'd take this movie so
you have mafia real I did this movie
called the mezzos about two gang
gangsters once I did that he took that
real and we kept sending it to the New
York can we can analyze too it was all
Jeff Cowan's though he was a genius at
that [ __ ] he knew exactly what all this
[ __ ] started casting he didn't have your
taper but for a year and a half I either
ass bro that's a lot of people don't
know that I would have the low books and
I'd be depressed I never say the name of
the project forecasting the rightful
role what the character was the
description I was gonna read the scenes
I'd have everything I wrote everything
more team everything but yeah how you
doing buddy
you look like I shot you Chihuahua look
at you out there I'm good yeah like I
said you guys are truly savages that's
[ __ ] awesome no it was what we do on
the [ __ ] show me one of your next
couple dates you don't need dates up
front
yep the seventh the seventh that the
magic Apple is homey in Santa Monica
like I said it's a it's it's stand-up
comedy but not really stand-up comedy
Joey I don't want people to be misled
cuz I've been doing comedy for years
there's a lot of things it's a [ __ ]
fusion yeah it's always showing that
when they go what's that when they go to
that doing them what's the name of the
website it's a vampire bright Marty
Moreno
and that's it go down there and go let's
go see it if I know anything about
Martin Martin has grown a lot the last
couple years and that I used to see him
go up there and do jokes and you know
with with Gabriel Fluffy's are very
professional he wants clean from time to
time if you give him a tequila he'll
tell you to kick up the heat low but
just so he can laugh a little bit that's
the expression on people's faces but you
gotta keep the show a certain thing now
that Martine is doing his own thing you
know I've known Marty in a long time
he's a very dirty dude he was the
original organizer what was a limited
company associate production even
escaped or so okay but you know where
Cochino we're not married one time yeah
we do pay the onetime to do a show at
the improv and wife oh yeah equity no
that's a good models nice wow those
[ __ ] crazy others made me do copy
okay this you forgive you though is this
[ __ ] like 12 like [ __ ] 15 years this
how to be a never going to see no no no
this wasn't that was at least 10 years
ago we would have deep conversations
wonder if it's leaking now good don't
worry about yeah I got married for a
while but you got married yeah you start
the t-shirt line associate productions
it's been a long road from you were
married you were squeezed the models
titties at the same time yeah I was
aligned [ __ ] I was cheating I was I did
I cheated my whole life and dude after a
lot of [ __ ] reflection and traveling
and seeing the world that I lived my
life different I try not to [ __ ]
about anything anymore Joey you know I'm
Maya
my goal is to [ __ ] just [ __ ] to
comedy brain yeah it is it's funny
life is funny I love doing what I do man
yeah I love going to a town and doing
five shows I feel so fortunate that
people show up to the shows I try to go
up there with the best attitude and the
best I can get arrested you know I don't
go up there with [ __ ] notes and well
you know sometimes I do get high and I'm
sorry but that's part of the [ __ ]
show this part of the patois as they say
Lee anyway Martin man I'm happy it came
on thank you thank you so much for
having me cause I said man I know it's a
holiday [ __ ] thing we wanted to put a
podcast out on Monday morning just so
you guys would have some maybe I have
you drive to the [ __ ] you little
barbecue you little [ __ ] maybe you
gonna see the Will Ferrell movie text me
later and until have a safe flight
listen don't [ __ ] do me a favor people
don't [ __ ] don't forget this weekend I'm
in Vegas at the South Pointe Friday's
Saturday 7:30 show you out of there by
9:00 you could go over to the MGM and
still see Joe Rogan's 10 o'clock show
Tony Hinchcliffe will do a half-hour Joe
go up so if you get a second that's the
combination you wanna do it you're gonna
be in Vegas that's the way to go next
weekend I'm at the [ __ ] st. Louis
helium next weekend back with the
brothers and some white dudes and then
too we set to them at the Borgata in
Atlanta Saturday night one show
bing-bang-boom philadelphia don't sleep
don't tell me and tell you [ __ ]
anyway I want to thank Martin Moreno no
website no nothing Martin Moreno calm
didn't okay now we're talking thank God
to get two hours oh sorry yep told me
Evan brighter the [ __ ] no no event
Friday's wooded thicket Lincoln yes
right I know just go to your website
yeah the [ __ ] knows about nice where
he's been and what he's doing
you'll recognize him from Gabriel's show
on [ __ ] Comedy Central and for many
other things he's done beside that you
know I love you [ __ ] with all
my heart
right when I believe trying to tell you
about the best things going on that's
why I talk to you about on it that's the
real reason I talk to you about you
think I both smoke up your ass
you go to my house you know I got my
house and the [ __ ] cabinet right next
the refrigerator two things a [ __ ]
Coco hemp force well I got nothing going
on and if I'm hungry I'll drink a
protein shake if I got something going
on and one in jujitsu some I would drink
a protein shake when I get back with two
scoops up I'm carving up with a half a
banana water ice cubes and I'll tell you
some on it the [ __ ] head boys protein
shake is tremendous after a workout
think like 30 to 33 grams of protein
with your body to the only assimilate
dirty if you [ __ ] lucky
gonna calm right now go to that box
check out the great little supplements
they got from alpha brain to the truth
tech to new mood they have a great
selection go check it out your life some
I'm gonna give you 10% off oh yeah those
go to the box and press in church BAM
CH you are CH and now you're [ __ ]
runnin things you understand me excuse
me let me talk to you people my son
these days you can basically practically
get everything on the man like the
podcast like the church you can listen
to whatever you want when it's
convenient to you correct so why the
hell are you still going to the post
office and dealing with them limited
hours the long line the cave you got to
bring it back now then I gotta take a
walk around the block to get you things
that you get postage on demand right now
with stamps calm anything you can do
with the post office you could do right
from your desk again right from your
desk with stamps.com buy and print
official US postage so any letter
package using your own computer and
printer and unlike the post office stamp
calm never closes
so you can get postage whenever you need
it 24/7
listen I've used that comma for Lee has
had it my wife I still use I mean listen
my wife loves it okay you gotta send
them packages out t-shirts for the show
whatever stamps calm is the way to go
listen I don't care who's out there what
you can do stamps.com is the way to go
now right now use my name Joey Jo ey for
the special offer for week trying to
give you and it includes postage and
raven is a digital scale that's how I
roll
call it stamps calm before you do
anything else before you go to the
bathroom for you chuckling milk for the
stance comm click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Joey jail we wide-set simple
that's that
stamps.com and to Joey again stamps.com
never go to the post office again no
bueno no good you don't know nothing you
don't know nothing you don't want to
know nothing and that's the way this
show ends I love you [ __ ] from
the bottom of my heart don't forget
about me Friday Saturday South Pointe
7:30
all right behind there by [ __ ] 9:00
next weekend
helium Southpoint who's better than you
and me nobody but my brothers in the
[ __ ] struggle I'll see you there and
if not two weeks from now Philadelphia
Camden Pennsauken the Peterborough I'll
see you at the Borgata [ __ ] have
a great fourth of July
you know me dog you can play with
[ __ ] firecrackers just keep them away
from the [ __ ] kids all right and keep
them away from the animals don't be a
[ __ ] scumbag have a great fourth of
July with your family stay black I love
you thanks again to martine moreno
doctor
you